all right well we are starting today
with hurricane Ian in Florida and uh
they they don't call it a disaster for
nothing this is not really a weather
show but there's been a lot of political
stuff revolving around the hurricane to
get everybody up to speed many trapped
in Florida as Ian heads towards South
Carolina reported by the Associated
Press
um there are rescue crews 2.5 million
Florida homes per the Associated Press
without power 2.7 million homes without
power according to other reports Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis told a news
conference we've never seen storm surge
of this magnitude it is basically a 500
year flooding event
when it comes to casualties hundreds are
feared dead now it takes a while to
officially get those numbers but we now
have heard from multiple political
leaders who are saying listen we're
being told about dozens if not hundreds
just in our municipality
so you start adding that up and unless
everybody's wrong you're talking about
at least hundreds dead
um The Daily Beast reporting that as
well as Millions more were plunged Into
Darkness in one of the most powerful
storms in American history and then uh
AFP and Yahoo news reporting floods
Devastation after Hurricane Ian hammers
Florida so there's a couple different
things I think that are important to
mention here for a show like ours first
of all we see a completely different Ron
DeSantis that I sort of knew existed in
the sense that I've told you all before
DeSantis is not a stupid guy his
incredible violent partisanship uh maybe
acute partisanship is is a better phrase
for it is a sort of a calculated
decision I'm not saying he's not a right
winger but he can get along with
everybody when he chooses to and he has
said Joe Biden's been good at helping
and everybody's getting along and this
is not the time for pettiness and it
again it's just another reminder that
it could be like this all the time if
people just wanted to be more reasonable
because that's all that's happening
DeSantis is just being more reasonable
in part because he knows that his
re-election could potentially hinge on
is he seen as handling the hurricane
correctly in addition you know when
covet started many of us naively and
incorrectly thought this will bring the
country together we're all going to
unite against the virus and then we did
many Republicans essentially taking the
side of the virus ignoring all
suggestions and guidelines and
recommendations and not getting
vaccinated all that different stuff okay
fine with the hurricane we're just all
going to no
you've got people claiming that the
hurricane is a hoax now what does it
mean what does it mean that it's a hoax
some of them say well it was a rainstorm
but it wasn't really that bad and this
was just a way to get the hurricane in
the media
to avoid talking about
fill in the blank right whatever it is
this was a distraction some claiming
that it was a geode engineered weather
event of some kind again for whose
benefit it's like never really
completely clear others fixating on the
evacuation orders and are they legal or
not and mandatory and all these
different things folks it's a hurricane
okay oh and actually I should say some
also
immediately fixating on wanting to blame
climate change for this particular
hurricane and as we've talked about
before climate change is not really
about any particular hurricane but
climate change models would predict that
we would have more extreme events and
that the events themselves would be more
extreme but I I you know we don't need
to play the game of this particular
hurricane was caused by climate change
and
um uh uh uh human activities on the
planet we don't need to do that the
climate change models don't require that
so I think that that to the extent that
people on the left are doing it also
doesn't make sense the priority is
getting power back on
reducing fatalities as much as possible
um and starting to get things back
together and we will let you know how
things are looking by Monday the only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream our
long time sponsor on curiosity stream
you will find the best selection of
documentaries better than any other
platform they've got the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles I've been
watching curiosity stream in my living
room I recently watched the six episode
series Inside the Mind of a con artist
I'm fascinated by scammers and cons and
how they get away with what they do
really great series that I can recommend
to you curiosity stream is always adding
new content they've got documentaries by
filmmakers we know and love but they
make it easy to find new independent
documentaries as well if you want to
absorb as much as you can curiosity
stream is for you if you want to retain
very little once you turn off the TV you
can also just relax with like a nature
documentary curiosity stream has those
two and with the special discount for my
audience you can get curiositystream for
15 bucks a year not not a month a year
that's under two bucks a month go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below